we really emphasize the ways in which
strategy is an ongoing iterative process
that it is an essential part of what you
do as a leader whether you think about
what you're doing when you're doing it
as strategy or not so you're doing
strategy all the time every time you
make a decision because at the most
basic level strategy is just about
deciding how to allocate your resources
so every time you make a decision about
whether to buys inputs from one supplier
or another or whether to you know invest
in this facility or to do this marketing
plan you're doing strategy and and our
fundamental view is it's better to do
that self-consciously and to be aware
that you're doing it and to not be aware
of it and so I think we oftentimes kind
of could benefit from demystifying what
strategy is and just realize that a lot
of us and a lot of different managerial
and leadership roles are doing strategy
all the time and it's better to be
self-reflective about it than to be
doing it blindly
a strong leader is somebody who who's
almost able to think like a scientist
who's constantly able to move back and
forth between the kind of the conceptual
model or the the theory of the way they
think the world works and the reality
that they're encountering and then
they're able to translate the
experiences that we're having or that
you're having as a group into a sensible
way of thinking about the world that the
rest of the group can really get on
board with and I think so really what
leaders do is they kind of build a
community right that the responsibility
of a leader is to think about the group
as a whole in the social group that
they're operating in a manager is
usually more concerned with kind of
technical aspects of of getting the job
done so how do I build kind of the most
efficient process but people also need a
sense of belonging and they need a sense
of kind of community in a sense of
purpose and I think that's really what
the leaders goal is
you have a plan that you want to execute
and part of your job as a strategic
leader is really to turn that plan into
coherent action right and part of that
is about what investment decisions you
make and how you allocate your resources
but a lot of it is also about how you
organize your people and the way you
structure the incentives the way you
structure reporting relationships how
much attention you pay to the culture
what kind of culture that you want to
have and even at the level of things
that we think of as kind of HR like
things like recruiting and who it is
that you're going to bring onto the team
those things are all incredibly
important because if you don't have the
alignment between the way you've set up
your organization and the strategy
you're trying to accomplish and kind of
the key assumptions in that strategy
you're not going to be successful I
think the core question and strategy is
about you know when you have an
innovation or when you have an idea and
you kind of see an opportunity there the
problem that a lot of innovators run
into is that they they focus almost
entirely on the nature of the
opportunity they really think about wow
this product is really going to do
something different for people and
that's not easy to do right it is very
hard to come up with great innovations
but actually the harder part and the
thing that we really emphasize in this
course is it's not enough to come up
with the innovation you also have to
come up with the plan for how you're
going to profit from that innovation and
that is oftentimes much more difficult
and part of that involves really
recognizing what the obstacles are that
stand in your way and those can be
obstacles in terms of powerful buyers or
suppliers they can be obstacles in terms
of rivals or potential entrants into the
industry how do you build a plan how do
you build a strategy that's going to
allow you to overcome those obstacles
because often times you come to the
table with this great insight about an
innovation that's going to have value
and there's a lot of work and getting to
that point and we'd really hate to see
the the work that you've done up until
that point go to waste because you never
figured out how to actually capture the
value that you're generating
so I think you know when we think about
leadership we tend to think about
particular individuals right so we think
about Gandhi or Martin Luther King or
Steve Jobs or kind of these great
figures that we kind of all kind of
think of as role models and and I think
it's important to learn lessons from
people like that but I think it's also
important to remember that you are who
you are and that you have your own
personality that you bring to the table
and your own strengths and your own
weaknesses and that effective leaders
are ones who recognize what their
strengths are and recognize what their
weaknesses are and build their
leadership style around that and it's
really important to have alignment
between what your leadership style is
and the kind of organization that you
build and the kind of strategy that you
that you pursue I think we too much too
great of an extent think about leaders
as something that is innate I think
everybody has leadership potential and
it is something that they can develop
over time I think it could be learned by
turning to others and asking them for
kind of you know in-depth and kind of
brutally honest kind of assessments of
what what your strengths and weaknesses
are I don't think there's any doubt
though that everybody has the potential
to be a powerful leader in the right
situation and at the right time